I think as was stated just now
regrettably the nuclear threats are not
at their low point I think frankly the
issues the the possibility of a nuclear
bomb going off are higher today than
they were 20 years ago not in the
massive us Soviet exchange that was of
course the Cold War concern but in terms
of the various regional conflicts that
that that we are facing but that's
another long story I will I will move
ahead to the assigned topic of
maintaining the nuclear Iran agreement
after I say a few words about Barbara
the barbara Lee you have you heard it
but I want to reinforce it somebody who
has spent ten years basically in in the
government that that she has been a
great leader both in the security and in
the domestic domains she did just use a
phrase and I want to quote taking out
those who don't support this now taking
out is an ambiguous term it sounds like
something that maybe some others would
use but I assume you mean electorally
electorally right all right very good
good the but she also mentioned the 2004
Democratic convention here and that of
course brings up John Kerry again and I
want to emphasize that John John and I
of course kind of at the end we
basically code negotiated the Iran
agreement but I also want to point out
this is a little bit now of you know
Boston bragging with John and me Gina
McCarthy John Holdren Brian Deese we are
talking about the Boston climate
warriors so you know the that team was
also very very heavily from Boston
Boston rip broadly
which had senators so uh so anyway it
was like it was a great time and we got
I think we did get some some things done
so let me turn to the no option when I
have one more assign and this goes to
again to Barbara and her Appropriations
role and the earlier question at the end
of the last panel about the budget
balance or imbalance and the threat to
science and a and a science career I
just want to say flat out don't let
something like this little blip
discourage you from a science career for
one thing just look at the budget that
the Congress did this week frankly none
of the major proposals that I think
caused a lot of us a lot of policy
heartburn were put into that budget in
fact if I look at the Department of
Energy for obvious reasons I got a lot
of emails saying looks like your budget
and it is very close to the budget we
put forward and a reason one of the
reasons is I don't want to be
Pollyannish but the reality is support
for the science agenda for the
innovation agenda yeah this noise but
fundamentally that is strong and that is
bipartisan I think Barbara would would
support that so that's why you know I do
think there are elements of stability
that will preserve a lot of these budget
budget priorities going forward it does
take work I'm trying to say it doesn't
take vigilance and work because there
are other voices but but I think as long
as we keep speaking we keep acting
there's aidil there's a very very strong
foundation for for funding on supporting
those kinds of priorities okay
finally I will turn to the topic I was
given maintaining the Iran nuclear
agreement as was said this was certainly
I think an important an example of
diplomacy reaching critical security
goals without a shot being fired I also
want to put in a plug for science and
diplomacy as something that was
important in the
in this case but you know what one can
ask the question and many people here I
I don't want to insult anybody but it
would appear to be of my age group and
probably do have a certain history but
there are a lot of young people as well
I just want to emphasize that the as one
sees the the almost the difficulty of
accepting the success of the agreement
in many ways one has to remember a very
very long difficult history between Iran
in the United States and regrettably in
a certain sense we've lost a period in
which the United States was actually a
hero to the Iranian people Harry Truman
President Truman was recognized for
example as explicitly declining to
support I'll be straightforward British
ideas of a coup in in with their first
elected leader in in Iran unfortunately
in 1953 that changed and the coup took
place and one has to remember that then
of course we had to remember 1979 when
Iranians took over the US Embassy
Americans died
not to mention hostage a lot of hostages
for a long time then there was the
iran-iraq war where and I heard this a
lot during the off hours of the
negotiation where the West bluntly stood
by while chemical weapons were used
against against Iran in the 1990s what I
did serve in the Clinton administration
it's not obviously so well known but
Iran was constantly on the agenda
because of Russia Iran collaboration
this is post Soviet Union Russia Iran
collaboration on nuclear issues very
complicated time NATO expansion would go
Kosovo would go through all kinds of
issues with the US and Russia but it
spilled over in
to a block on our ability to move
forward on important nuclear security
issues with Russia because of the Iran
dynamics at that time the then we go
into the next century and we have the
axis of evil we have the 2003 Iraq war
where look you know Iranian supplied
IEDs did a lot of damage to American
personnel and of course today we have
Hezbollah we have Syria Yemen Iraq
missiles human rights this is a
complicated situation and so all I'm
saying is the grounds of distrust are
very very deep and that has to be
recognized in going into this Iran
agreement it makes it even more
remarkable in a certain sense that this
agreement could then be could then be
accomplished with this background but
here now is where I want to emphasize
what's very important is that the
decision was taken by President Obama
very early in the administration both to
have a dialogue there had been some
dialogue in the George W Bush years but
to have a dialogue that did not start
out with a whole set of preconditions
first and secondly that was focused
exclusively on the existential threat of
nuclear weapons and did not in any way
attempt to solve at the same time all
those other issues I talked about that
by the way is not particularly different
from what President Reagan did in the
1980s on arms control with the Soviet
Union it wasn't as though arms control
was the only issue we had with the
Soviet Union at the height of the Cold
War but the choice was made to address
this existential threat much of the
critique that you hear if you listen
carefully about the Iran deal is not
about the deal at all it's about what
the deal is not
in addressing these other these other
issues so I think that's a that's a I
think an important kind of context for
for the discussion so in a nutshell
what's the agreement I think in this in
this audience I'm sure many people are
familiar so I'll just be very high level
but the fundamental structure of the
agreement is that the Iran nuclear
program that was expanding very
dramatically 20,000 centrifuges close to
a reactor that would be one to two bombs
worth of plutonium per year etc advanced
R&D program so that program is both
stopped and dramatically rolled back
with major it is not zeroed out but it
is rolled back very very dramatically
important constraints on the program for
15 years so that gets 15 years of again
a highly restricted program but then and
Barbara mentioned this and it's not
mentioned enough and I really want to
thank you for focusing on it what is
probably I think more important in the
agreement are the extraordinary
transparency and verification measures
in fact in fact in my list of that
difficult history between Iran and
United States it's also between Iran and
the international community in the sense
that around 2003 Iran got caught frankly
being outside the lanes on its nuclear
program and that is what ultimately led
to the strong regime of sanctions and
international collaboration okay so the
the again the grounds of distrust SAR
are unfortunately in many ways quite
quite real so the transparency measures
without strong transparency measures
that could not be an agreement and in my
view quite appropriately as a result
however
we have a whole bunch of unique features
for example no one else has verification
activities on the uranium supply chain
no one else has verification activities
yeah I mean this is like cameras and I a
IAEA inspectors on the manufacturing of
key parts other countries do have the
Additional Protocol not all but many the
Additional Protocol for those not
familiar with it is the agreement with
the International Atomic Energy Agency
for them to have access to suspicious
sites not just sites that the country
declares to be nuclear sites that's very
important and Iran has agreed in
perpetuity to be in the Additional
Protocol however no other country as a
fixed time in which to respond to that
inspector request and frankly to use a
technical term there's a lot of
rope-a-dope to just stretch out the
response with Iran there's two weeks for
the IAEA and them to resolve the issue
and if not it automatically goes to a
10-day clock where there is access or
there is a violation of the agreement
this is completely novel other countries
most countries fortunately unfortunately
if you not most belong to them to the
non-proliferation treaty the
non-proliferation treaty says you won't
have a nuclear weapon it doesn't say
that you will not engage in
weaponization activities the kinds of
technical steps you would need to go
quickly to a weapon Iran has those
constraints in this in this agreement so
this is it's quite remarkable did Garwin
and other scientists or a letter to
President Obama in August of 2015
saying just that and saying by the way
wouldn't it be great if we could get
these kinds of measures to be part of
the norm and apply and applied much more
broadly so that's what the what the
agreement is so now maintaining
obviously is I think there's John whom
who mentioned that a lot of noise in the
system despite the fact that the
quarterly required the required
quarterly report report to Congress
recently did again affirm compliance
with the with the agreement but ask the
question what happens if we do walk away
if the United States walks away from the
agreement then we get the worst of both
worlds then Iran has no formal
constraints they will they may choose to
continue to live under some of the
constraints but probably not those
unique verification measures and we may
say okay or some may say some her
colleagues who's particularly mostly sit
across the aisle they'd say okay but
we'll put we'll put sanctions back on
and sanctions were biting we could say
that it won't work the reason it worked
before was we had the entire
international community or the essential
international community on the same page
enforcing those sanctions not just those
who negotiated the p5 plus 1 + EU but
India Japan they were withholding oil
revenues from from Iran according to the
sanctions there is no reason to think
that if we walk away we don't walk away
alone maybe one other country would be
with us from that negotiating group but
we're going to walk away alone
fundamentally and the sanctions will not
will not be effective so many of those
including many of those in Congress
nitrogens mentioned for example senator
corker chair of the Foreign Relations
Committee the Senate
he's explicitly said look I didn't
support the deal but now it's done now
the important thing
is we maintain compliance agreement with
the deal by all parties that means us
too and so I can't say you know
obviously I cannot say there's no doubt
this deal will will stick will go
forward but I can say that the logic is
completely clear and compelling and most
people including those who did not agree
with the deal have kind of kind of come
to that so we will see what the
administration what the administration
review says but I guess I am let's say
reasonably optimistic that we will
continue in this way and then I will put
out one more challenge and that's for
all of us and then that which includes
in in my next in my nti role this will
be something that we will want to be
looking at let's suppose we have success
in terms of compliance with this
agreement we have got to think hard
about what then what do we want to see
in Iran and elsewhere in the region and
beyond
in terms of nuclear fuel cycles it would
be crazy to keep doing our quarterly
review and saying compliance compliance
compliance and come to the end and not
have a program which could include for
example working on those transparency
measures in the broader international
context so that to me is the agenda
we've got to be vigilant we've got to
try to sustain the agreement clearly but
we also need to think about what's the
future that we want to see in this
decade all time scale as we as we come
hopefully to the end of a successful
agreement thank
[Applause]
[Music]